the president's first press conference
from the Star Wars orbiting peace
platform got off to a shaky start when
power failed causing a brief but
harmless period of weightlessness for
the visiting president and his staff
will be back in a moment
don't buy wigs that come off at the
wrong time
mauriz wings backs arcade on Roddy's
it's Channel 4 News at 6 o'clock the
trilogy knows booty sweat up in a house
open what's my name
dargah Gino danke danke Jena
turbo man buzz wonder available at all
houseboy fallon outlets and the dragon
why remember a destructive love affair
garrett lacunae we have perfected a safe
effective technique for the focused
erasure pick up your phone and call the
professionals go those [ __ ] talk
about a hole in one
chances are you bought them already for
relaxing times make it Suntory time on
local San Diego legend champ kind and I
believe in two things good chicken and
that the census is a way for the UN to
make your children gay eighth generation
Waylon time technological intellectual
Jeff Portnoy and Jeff Portnoy Oh
he has queen mattress sets for $99 and
king sets for 129 my name is Jim
Cunningham and welcome to controlling
fear I said we got a winner here we got
a winner
I'm Ricky Bobby you don't chew big red
than you
America's plate retain Joe and that's
who I care about you like music the pill
why don't you let me fix you some of
this pneumo cocoa drink all natural
cocoa beans from the upper slopes of
Mountain occur agua no artificial
sweeteners where do you go when you want
to buy name-brand spatulas at a fraction
of retail customer city-by-city hey Luca
get them before they get you you'd point
your fingers and go bang bang and the
other kid would lie down and pretend
that well Westworld is the same thing oh
holy it's for real you too can become
financially independent in just a matter
of months
[Music]
Wow come on Nana see me folks let me out
Kathleen Bauer here at Globo gym
we understand that ugliness and fatness
are genetic disorders the nester
class-five is tomorrow's robot today
Magna Bowl lethal response join the
mobile infantry and save the world
service guarantees citizenship I'd buy
that for a dollar